s bonour àous et bienven dans consr
aujourd'hui nom d'espè au président
desatsunisom nouvelles espèces qu'il
découvre et parfois il décide tout
simplement de leur donner le nom de
[Musique]
politicien prier Nita pourquoi donner un
nom de personnalité politique à une
espèce et bien cela peut-être pour la
critiquer par exemple comme ce fut le
cas pour le ver crutchevia ridicula très
explicitement nommé pour nuire au chef
d'État de l'URS de l'époque Nikita
keved President ge W Bush not bele
eating h certes c'est vrai que la
plupart du temps on nomme les espèces
pour honorer nos chefs d'État mais dans
le cas d'agathtidium bushi j'ai moi
aussi un peu de mal à voir en quoi
baptiser ce scarabé mangeur d'excréments
et charognard serait un honneur pour
l'ancien président Bush mais au fait
pourquoi focaliser notre attention sur
les présidents américains
particulièrement et bien tout simplement
parce qu'il semblerait que les
chercheurs des autres pays soi plutôt
radin pour ce qui est de donner le nom
de leur chef d'État à des espèces
vivantes en France par exemple il n'y en
a eu qu'un et ça remonte déjà à bien
loin quoi c'est tout c'est ça donne que
ça la traduction y ok bon ben alors
c'est parti pour une petite liste non
exhaustive d'espèces nommées à partir de
président des États-Unis
é commençons d'abord par les présidents
les plus emblématiques George Washington
et Abraham Lincoln respectivement 1ier
et 16e président des États-Unis et à qui
on doit les fondations de cet état ainsi
que l'abolition de
l'esclavage President Thomas jeffon is
one who most often gave his name in the
biologicalure great accomplishment as
exp
natural parmi ces fondateurs de l'État
américain c'est certainement le 3è
président Thomas Jefferson qui fut le
plus souvent immortalisé dans la
nomenclature biologique il fut en effet
l'un des artisans de l'exploration du
territoire américain un grand
naturaliste et surtout il fut le premier
paléontologue né sur le le territoire
américain c'est le seul président
paléontologue de toute
l'histoire en effet comme le dit ma
collègue Jefferson fut le premier
citoyen des États-Unis à décrire un
fossile nordaméricain on lui doit
notamment la description du paresseux
géant megalonix et c'est pourquoi de
nombreuses espèces éteintes furent nommé
ensuite en son
honneur
un autre président célèbre pour ses
explorations est Teddy Roosevelt qui
entre autres vertébré et invertébré de
tout poil a vu son nom être associé à la
sous-espèce de ser la plus grande du
continent
nordaméricain luimême et son fils ont
d'ailleurs découvert des espèces
jusqu'àors inconnu de mammifère en
Afrique et en Asie du Sud-Est theosev
family family of GL Franklin roosev
turned his 1938 presidential Cruise into
a naturalist trip and brought back in
Quan of specimens from Europe and South
America
therefore toujours dans la famille
Roosevelt décidément une grande famille
de Glob trotur frankck la Roosevelt a
transformé sa croisière présidentielle
de 1938 en un véritable voyage de
naturaliste duquel il a ramené quand
spécim de France et d'Amérique du Sud
ainsi beaucoup d'espèces souvent exoti
ont reçu son nom et pour finir il est
des présidents dont on distribue le nom
simplement parce que les scientifiques
les aiment
beaucoup bar Obama
clintonary Clinton Bill Clinton et Jimmy
Carter ça va oui
parmies présidents le plus adul d'entrex
est sans doute Barack Obama en juger par
la dizaine d'espèces qui lui sont dédié
et qui inclu un oiseau des poissons un
reptile fossile et même des petits ver
parasites mi mi
mi
toutes ces espèces furent nommées en son
honneur pour saluer sa politique de
défense et de promotion en matière
d'écologie d'éducation de Scien de santé
publique et de
biodiversité to name species is act of
selfomotion byes Politi or indrial
company Scien can raise the interest of
the public ecology enourage our Leers
Act
pour un scientifique baptiser une espèce
n'est pas seulement une façon de se
donner de l'importance donner le nom
d'un politicien ou d'une Compagnie
Industrielle à une espèce c'est saisir
l'opportunité de piquer au vif la
curiosité du public et des autorités et
de tourner leur centre d'intérêt vers
l'écologie et la protection de
l'environnement nommer une espèce c'est
donner de l'importance à ce qui tient à
cœur aux scientifiques une démonstration
de leur engagement politique N
[Musique]
pasésoublier
ce que tu as dit
là et c'est sûr que de toutes les
espèces à qui on pouvait donner le nom
de Donald Trump le nouveau président des
États-Unis il a fallu que ce soit C ours
vieux de million d'années sachant les
incointances clairement créationnistes
de Donald Trump il est très ironique de
voir son nom associé à un fossile
démontrant que la terre est bien plus
vieille que ne le disent les
écritures ouais tu as raison pourvu que
ce petit clin d'œil l'encourage à
promouvoir l'enseignement de la théorie
de l'évolution dans les
écoles
[Musique]